you've become a role model for a lot of
young girls being comfortable in your
own skin and owning who you are being
happy and confident about who you are at
this place helped shape you uh it
definitely helped tear me down enough to
help me bring myself back up not the
show but Media the show helped me a lot
I mean the show I was trying to buy so
many great people that were really
supportive of me and really you know
wanted me to thrive and you know told me
all the time that you know they believed
me and that I um you know I should be
confident and all those things and they
were so wonderful to me but all the
success that we got so early and
especially being so young and being part
of that success we were criticized a lot
and I was criticized especially being
the youngest girl out of the cast
ariel's Modern Family co-stars
praised her for being unapologetically
comfortable in her own skin I'm always
like you know why why you showing so
much of your body and why and don't you
and then she's like why not and I'm very
comfortable with who I am and and she
knows exactly who she issues exactly and
I watched so much negativity bounce
right off her and I'm like let me learn
from you when the teacher becomes the
student she's great she's a great
actress she's super professional we love
her and said she has never given us you
know a recent - to be upset it's
fantastic actually all the kids on the
set are like an amazing role model to
all kids because they behave really nice
would you say - maybe a young girl out
there who's struggling maybe like you
with our confidence or not really
knowing which way to go or how to feel
about herself or a body at the end of
the day the only person you should be
trying to make happy as yourself and not
other people
[Music]